[Musique]
cette petite fille va devenir célèbre
elle s'appelle catherine demongeot et
louis malle l'a choisie pour jouer le
rôle de zazie dans le film qu'il
s'apprête à tourner à partir du roman de
raymond queneau zazie dans le métro
presque tout le monde connaît zaz qui
est déjà presque aussi célèbre que
monsieur de la palice on parle
volontiers comme l'asie au père de
catherine est peintre en bâtiment zazie
donc est une petite fille qui incarne
l'impertinence et dans le vocabulaire
exprime par sa grossièreté le désir de
mettre les fameux gros mot à la portée
des grandes personnes voici comment
parlera zazie dans le film n'a pas loupé
qui m'intéresse pas tous sauf les idiots
japonais est ce que vous pouvez être sûr
noir allons faut pas vous dis comme ça
je voulais raconter mon histoire vous
souvenez la couture et en 111 caf un
deal crâne de son mari d'un coup de
hache
il ya c'était maman vous dire que maman
vous oublierez papa alors papa savez on
dit rice c'était lui à picoler ou suivi
elle s'est pris lui la cause de moi
c'est pas bien ça c'est pas une bonne
mère tu es tout seul
nous avons pensé que jouer un tel rôle
pour une petite fille qu'il devait poser
quelques problèmes
ils dansent cet éléphant et on titille
encore quel âge as-tu catherine est ce
que tu crois que zazi a existé
[Musique]
est ce que tu crois qu'il y a des
petites filles comme nazi beaucoup tia
koné non est ce que tu lui ressemble un
peu jazzy oui je sais pas comment elle
est
est-ce que tu ne ressemble pas du tout
qu'est-ce que tu parles de zazie est ce
que tu l'admirent pas tellement
est ce que tu lui reproches
tu sais pas cherche un peu
tu ne trouves pas un peu trop grossier à
base je la trouve pas un peu au pinceau
lente
pas tellement est-ce que zazie comprend
tout ce qu'elle dit d'après toi et
est-ce que tu comprends tout ce que
disent asie est ce qu'il t'arrive est de
dire des gros mots avant de jouer zazie
en présence de grandes personnes jamais
si l'asie est grossière et insolence et
que les grandes personnes là gaza est ce
que les grandes personnes agace moi je
te casse pas en ce moment un peu
pourquoi penses-tu que louis malle de
choisi pour jouer zazie est ce que tu
aimerais avoir un nom comme gabriel à
gros zoom qui dansera en tutu dans une
boîte de nuit
[Musique]
il ya des bonnes et des mauvaises
actions 1 tu es d'accord
cite moi l'exemple de bonnes actions une
mauvaise action gepam à casser un
carreau ce une mauvaise action réparer
un carrosse une bonne action tu es
d'accord jouer zazie au cinéma c'est une
bonne ou une mauvaise action
haha tu crois qu'il ya quelque chose
entre les bonnes et les mauvaises
jusqu'à présent j'imagine que des
parents ont toujours recommandé d'être
poli un bien peu lumineuse pas avec les
grandes personnes de lire bonjour
monsieur bonjour madame et de ne pas
répondre ne pas être insolent de ne pas
dire de gros mots
enfin bon et voilà que tout à coup
d'autres grandes personnes louis malle
te demande de jouer le rôle d'une petite
fille qui est le contraire de ce que tes
parents te demande d'être est ce que tu
trouves pas un peu bizarre il faut
passer un peu bizarre cinéma ouais mais
tu n'as pas l'impression que les grandes
personnes ne savent pas ce qu'elles
veulent tes parents à côté qui demandait
de police puis lui mal de l'autre qui
demande de jouer ce rôle là
si j'ai dit qu'il veut faire vos noces
avec mes parents c'est catherine
d'accord penses tu que jouer à être nazi
au cinéma te donne le droit de te
conduire et de te parler de parler comme
l'asie chez toi ils ont si tu dis des
gros mots aujourd'hui et si dieu est
insolente et site avant dans sa traque
qu'est ce que tu veux répondre a saisi
il fait bien à l'école tes camarades
savent que tu fais du cinéma
pourquoi paris pourquoi tu auras pas
parler pourquoi
qu'est ce qui t'amuse le plus dans le
tournage tout tout il n'y a pas des
personnages qui t'amuse plus que les
autres et l'ardeur de zazie verdure
perroquet qu'est ce qui lie le perroquet
du coach du coup c'est tout ce que tu
sais faire comme toi comme moi tu
m'aurais dit ça ya trois mois
[Musique]
nous madame êtes vous heureuse que votre
fille et elle est choisie pour jouer le
rôle de nazi
et vous monsieur vous avez lu zazie
madame oui j'ai lu le livre déjà lu j'ai
lu le livre de raymond caille aux
évolutions que zazie soit un
chef-d'oeuvre n'est pas en question mais
la grossièreté insolence de zazie ne
vous ont-elles pas choqué lorsque vous
avez pensez que votre petite fille
d'aller jouer ce rôle
je pense que c'est une violence surtout
verbale et qu'il n'y a rien de bien
grave dans tout cela et vous monsieur je
pense que ma faim vous ne vous êtes pas
demandé si jouer le rôle de zazie
n'allait pas un peu gâcher votre fille
oui évidemment mais ce n'est pas bien
grave
elle s'en remettra seul moi je ne crois
pas que cela gâche pas parce que je ne
pense pas qu'elle devienne
devient de sophistique j'ai l'impression
que les tendances dans l'éducation sera
spontané joie joie qu'elle reste
toujours spontané naturel
vous ne craignez pas qu'elle devienne
insolente ou grossière elle le sera
peut-être devenu de toute façon avec
large et vous monsieur
non elle c'est à dire sans vocabulaire s
enrichir la fois lécher le parquet sur
frais mangez l'époque de tableau noir
sur fond sera des combats dans la
verrière pautrat les fesses
[Musique]